why I'm here today talking to you here
in this amazing special place it's
because of a slag story basic slag story
you know how those story goes you know I
couldn't have my pocket money where
there was a kid you know grow up in
Switzerland you know picture this this
White Peak green field with nice little
chalet can you see that yeah well it's
not there it's up north
foggy raining the most job bless area in
Switzerland you usually never get away
from that place I live in a tiny village
it's a dead-end road there's nothing
after that you feel like you are at the
end of the world and I grow up there I'm
from there and I've got two brother
one older one younger and I keep going
back to my father saying I need some
pocket money give me money he said no
way I'm gonna get money anyway I know
him so much then one day say okay we
make a deal I've got the garden full of
slug you collect all dread shrugs and I
give you $1 hmm interesting
I spend all my time in a garden when he
was raining because those slug was
coming out when he was raining right
collect all those look 600 I need it and
what what I will do with those $6 I will
run in town and by National Geographic I
was 7 years old so tonight it's the
first presentation and I do here in
National Geographic DC and I'm really
proud to talk to you tonight
it's really something really deep in my
heart this is the example that dream
comes true because I want has a little
girl to travel to those weird incredible
places so I spent my childhood in the
forest I had this amazing
guidebook bird book you know on the
front page there was this beautiful blue
bird with a bit of red and yellowish
thing on the back but they forgot to
tell me that I was not in Europe and not
in my country so I spent all my
childhood in the woods looking for that
bird you know my parents were quite
happy I was knew would someone looking
for birds you know anyway I took my
revenge on this one and I would like to
invite you with me tonight we're gonna
be starving it's gonna be hot you can
see snakes and crocodile
welcome to dropped into the wild corner
my most recent expedition my concern was
how we can feed the world today because
I was in China I saw all these Chinese
people build houses like one look it's
really high and a lot of people in the
same room and I thought how are we gonna
do this how are we gonna keep using the
planet that way I was concerned about
it's gonna be somebody angry in this
world in some ways in some times coming
up how we can it do this so I decided to
take on a journey I wanted to understand
how we can do this go back to the route
at the time of the gather and Hunter yes
I will find my own food in my own turn
following the aberrant people they've
been doing this for sixty thousand years
right so but as usual
expedition really start when things go
wrong and start to be really going wrong
at the first minute of the expedition so
I learned in a little tone on the
northwest corner of Australia called
Canaan Inara word like like that long
it's that we've talked we'd turn where
you've got cowboy Aborigines people
mining people all mixed together arrived
there with a little airplane
land and I opened my phone my dear
friend supposed to be there helping me
for one month to go and check him all my
techniques survival techniques that I've
been learning over the years included
really technical fishing techniques and
I received is lovely text where he was
saying sorry darling I can't make it I
was like what we've been planning this
for a year how what and I tried to call
him like 15 five times never answer the
phone and I call my team back in
Switzerland I say hey guys how are you
gonna do this and my assistant was
getting agitated Sarah my god you you
have to leave in four weeks time how we
gonna do this I'd say you know that in
when things get agitated like that
there's only one option I'm gonna drink
coffee you know you know in nature when
there is a danger when there is
something so intense animals just
stopped and froze I'm just gonna stop
and froze and drink of it until I see
you sign on the front of me that's it
and I can hear my assistant you are
crazy darling I did that stop in the
coffee shop drink for five hours the
night went down I took my little car
when to find my accommodation that night
I booked a room in the farm and this
lady received me she was waiting for me
and she just walk out of the door of the
property she had the designer dress on
pink dress beautiful hair done makeup on
I was like what I'm in a remote location
in the bush in Australia and she's
wearing this kind of thing I thought
this woman never gonna help me not this
one you know went to bed anyway the next
morning she'll knock on my door and she
say Sarah do you want to have a coffee
with
me so lovely yeah why not you know
anyway we had coffee and she said what's
bring you here darling say well I'm
coming to walk I try not to deliver too
many information at the same time
because usually I get arrested before I
do anything so I learned my lesson in
China when I get arrested by the Special
Forces I learned my lesson in Lao when
the drug dealer arrest me I learned my
lesson in Mongolia when local man run
through my camp every night tried to
steal my stuff so yeah I was happy to do
some walking and she said she jumped on
her seat really literally jump and she
said well I just come back from Europe I
did the Camino in Europe I was like what
she was a broker
anyway she said you want some brownie I
said of course I want some brownie she
I've got some fresh brownie coming from
the oven I said yes let's have some
brownie
oh it's we start chatting like - woman
can chat and she said don't worry wait
she took the phone make like five phone
call she said okay you've got a meeting
tomorrow is this one then a coffee at
4:00 with this one dinner with this one
say who is this woman you will see go I
don't have time to come with you but you
manager anywhere in a week time and make
this networking of powerful woman in
this town the lawyer of the town the
doctor of the tone I had all of them on
the world my wings and they push me and
helped me to reboot my expedition
reroute copper team expedition restart
from scratch and four weeks later I was
ready to go but everybody then I was
talking to having the same conversation
over and over saying to me it's a
drought year there is not enough water
in the bush you will not be able to
survive everybody was saying that
and you know when people are always got
this opinion about my expedition they
look at me they judge me this they look
at me and they saying what is blondie
thing here she's she's not good for
these things you know
anyway I thought maybe this time I
better listen a little bit and I decided
to do a test and before I wanted to
spend some time with other people that's
how I made you Jew in a center it's a
full blood virgin woman really important
a woman in her community and the young
people around her is the new generation
they're they're the kids of her sister
so you can see the the pure blood it's
really rare to find some pure blood
evidence those days and we went on a
tour together in a bush we spent some
time in abortion she will give me some
tricks but she will not give me all the
tricks she didn't know that I know you
know she didn't know that I've been
preparing these things for 20 years so
she will give me the tricks but not all
of it she will give me the wrong plan to
look for not the good ripe one she would
give me the young one where there was no
nothing to eat there and I was wondering
more spend time with her what's going on
yeah why she doesn't give me the full
trick is it because she feel like I
don't own my passed through her land or
it is because she don't want me to get
hurt and go back home I didn't know what
she was thinking I didn't know what
everybody was thinking really I decided
to do a test and I just did that I went
Bush get dropped with a little plane
walk for seven days and discover exactly
what they were talking about there was
not enough food there they were right
actually so I decided to take a plan B
with me I decide to take hundred fifty
Seagram of flour per day as a plan-b if
things go wrong you know so look like
that it's a little flat bread and I
wonder today if it was a good idea
because you know when you've got in your
pack food you so starving but you're not
allowed to touch it it's like having the
fridge full of food and you like you in
a diet right can't touch it right it was
a river but I decide to to do this that
way so let's go we're gonna get dropped
with a helicopter northwest of Australia
precisely there there's nobody there
it's empty land no you aimin this for me
so get dropped there with the helicopter
the pilot said to me are you sure you
want to get drop here there is nothing
here it is exactly where I want to get
brought here I see okay good like and
you fly away and I can hear and then
nothing so we'll come in Australia well
we can see it's not flat at all right so
the good thing about this it's there is
valet here so on the bottom of the
valley we've got a bit of water so
you've got water bit of green thing
means we're gonna find food so there's
always a bit the same story you've got
water you've got frog frog you've got
snakes next we've got crocodile it goes
like that a bit like yeah so I knew that
so that's how I start my journey so rule
number one do not camp near the water do
not take your water two times is the
same spot the first time you're gonna be
okay
but the second time we will get you so
this kind of area there it's full of
things like crawling spider everywhere
snakes but two type of crocodile one is
Sweetwater crocodile they are lovely
really lovely clay creature they talk to
you you talk to them it's it's really
lovely relationship and then you've got
the other one it's a big salty crocodile
they eat cattle horses big thing human
another so they eat those things they
turn them around they put them
underneath the water under a log make
you leave you there for a few weeks so
you get really tender they go back there
so it's all about managing you landscape
right so I was there lovely camp look
afternoon I've got a little fire going
on my little house and far enough away
from the water so I'm there taking my
water so I'm really saved there so I've
got a bucket of water like a flexible
bucket of water like a plastic thing and
I put my row by the end of it and I
decide to take my water so I throw that
thing in the water and retrieve the
brackets and unfortunately the thing
didn't open properly I was like Sarah
Marquess really are you that good it's
gonna be good you know it can be really
long journée like that anyway
I start again open the thing throw that
thing in the water again and retrieve it
that's at this time I'm gonna get it
right I retrieved this bucket and
suddenly there was this branch in the
middle and I was like ah I haven't see
that branch really getting better and I
just did this little push like that you
know just for the bucket to go over the
branch and suddenly the branch was
pulling me back
that was my first crocodile sight yeah
that was the kind of Welcome Party you
know and that was the beginning of a
really long relationship so how you deal
with crocodiles
well you have to learn you have to be
aware of your surrounding at any moment
it's really important it's available for
us here also so that day there was a
special day that day I tell you I did
amazing discovery I was exhausted as
usual you know and starving because I've
been starving quite a lot and I was a
laundry day I wash a bit my stuff on the
way you know right so I had my long it's
like a strong shirts long sleeve and I
took some water and I decide to wash it
so I squeezed it and then I decided to
have a nice you know great of the order
little bear and suddenly I hear a noise
cwienke noise like that I was like what
and suddenly you I'm just like under the
bushes straight away looking for what's
going on because you don't want to stand
like I like big tall asparagus in the
middle of the bush I do not do this
right you have to be underground all the
time and then I'm there waiting to see
that bird because I have know all the
birds I know all the plants I've been
studying that landscape for days I need
never heard about that bird anyway I
forgot about that thing took my jacket
and smash it again I hear the same noise
like really but it was not coming from
the bush was chroming from that cliff
and on a bottom of the cliff I just get
on the edge over and I saw all these
little crocodiles line up talking to mom
I discovered that there the core of the
crocodile yeah scientific discovery see
so I've been studying this for a long
time before I had of an expedition
nobody could actually tell me what was
the trick to know if was a crocodile in
a water or not the abortion people used
to go in the water with two stone
getting inside the water and smash the
stone together and then that will make a
little noise and then they will know if
there is crocodile there well that's a
bit too late right you just in a water
already it's like the soup supper thing
you are on them anew so you don't want
that so I'm nobody never told me what to
do actually to know if it's the
crocodile there so I discovered the call
of the crocodile that there and that was
a good day for me because the day coming
on from there
I will actually smash my shirt put a bit
of water on the bottom and I will
actually discover if there was Caudill
there or not so when you're going to do
those things the only thing you have to
know you have to be able to read the
landscape like a treasure map I will
find sometimes some water just because I
found a little bird on the type of type
of tree because I know all those birds
the little red bird the diamond Finch I
know they can fly five kilometres around
only and I know they have to drink two
times a day so I know there would be
water around or if I find the type of
pens I will know exactly what can of
roots I can find and I can find my food
my food it's all I've got
you know you know you realize after you
peel you know it's life it's like an
onion you peel the onion once you peel
where you come from who you are
in this society and you get to the core
of things you realise then things are
really simple actually we are we all
want the same thing we want the family
to be safe we want food water shelter by
thick
that was my Waring this is my breakfast
every morning would be
easy for me to find my breakfast I will
eat those kapok flower and those flower
are incredible because a bit juicy a bit
gooey no much test but that will fill my
tummy so after a while after a few weeks
my tummy will actually the side of my
tummy will stick together now I will be
so starving like I couldn't sleep at
night and that's after three weeks I
thought I was hungry but wait took me
three months you know so I start to get
better and looking for food and this is
a typical good day
where it spawned a new spiralis this is
a bunch of a plant spike is plant very
spiky so the way to eat this is to go in
the middle with your legs it's not much
easy way right you want the fresh little
young in the middle so you take if you
han you have to embrace the pain in one
stage right so you're going in either
you grab the spiky thing and then in a
really quick fast go you collect the
middle bit and then if you lucky at the
end of it you've got two centimeters to
three centimeters of white chewing thing
and it's actually fiber you can eat that
that will fill up my tummy it's all
about filling the tummy you know I will
walk 12 hour a day climbing going to
really harsh terrain and then I will
reach that tree this tree will be on my
way all the time what do you think about
it it's like a lot of fruit right so I
reach this tree and I look at the tree
and look on the ground first thing look
on the ground no kangaroo no birds
eating that thing there is no
poo on the bottom of that tree no sign
of anybody using that tree I don't like
it but I'm starving you know so look at
that tree I'm thinking well you know
what I learn how to do thing yeah I'm
good you remember that's surviving so
the rules is to take the fruit smash it
in your new wrists here that's the most
thing skin than we've got and then if
there is no reaction
you know the fruit it's kind of edible
then you go phase number two you put a
bit of thing inside you must hear no
reaction you can go for the tongue wait
for us because some of those fruit you
need to wait for the toxic to get out of
the thing
if you kind of safe after four hours if
you got no tingling in the mouth or in
the tongue right I know that right what
so what I do I get there take the fruit
squeeze ago because I don't feel like it
you know because I'm really starving
right so I did that like pose like with
like a Schweppes like like shrimp some
steroid you know like oh my god did is
disgusting and I try to split it out and
and everything and I was like oh one
more Sarah anyway I passed that tree and
I keep over the days I keep me I keep
having that tree on my on my journey and
every time I see that tree I'm like
frustrated you know and one thing you
don't want to get me frustrated she said
do not do this so I get to that tree
again and I like to talk to him and say
right I know you're not good for me but
let's try a little bit again and I
squeezed again a little bit squeeze and
I start to kind of like it you know like
you know we think we cannot get used to
think well we can use to a lot of things
you can get used to things I start to
get used to this video horrible test and
one day I was very tired
one of those very bad day and I saw that
tree many times on my way during the
hours loving this wrong day and I keep
sitting under that tree and having a go
until when I start to stand up I had
this blurred vision of the landscape I'm
thinking too much of a good thing it's a
bad thing right
so I abuse of this substance on the head
I lose it I lose my vision so you learn
on the way also I know a lot of things
but we learn on the way the only way to
learn is to get out of our comfort zone
jump out and be here and test it this is
the only way to grow to get to that
beautiful people that we all are in this
in this room this is available for the
lives is what it's a life lesson get out
there and try don't stay in your own
juice this is my rule because when you
know how to do things you become a
master of what you do and then what's
boring you don't grow you start to be a
bit not a happy person
let's get out there try a few different
things you never know what's gonna
happen
[Music]